hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome and complicated game that was
played yesterday on the rest today yes
it was played on a rest today because uh
even though it was supposed to be played
in round one nippo's um uh plane had a
delay and uh he landed um a bit late so
they decided to postpone the game until
the rest day so now it was played and
before we continue uh round five we have
to check it out as it features quite an
amazing moment it's a very very very
complicated game and features another
berlin defense uh but takes a slightly
different turn than the one that uh
magnus had against nipple in their
classical game so without further ado
let's check it out danny pomerci versus
sergey king uh let's see what happens so
here uh nepo opens with e4 we have e5
knight to f3 and knight to c6 with
bishop to b5 the rue lopez is on the
board and now the berlin defense knight
to f6
uh we have castles and now knight
captures an e4 so everything the same
like in the game magnus versus nipple
here d4 knight to d6 captures on c6d
captures and now of course the captures
on e5 and we're going to have a queen
trade knight f5 we have captures
captures and now in the game against the
magnus magnus played a rook to d1 check
against nipple but here niepo against
hariakan goes knight to c3 and this is
for a very particular reason that we're
gonna discuss in uh only a few moves uh
and also i forgot to mention i hope you
guys are having an excellent sunday uh
king the e8 uh you want to develop this
light square bishop and then bring the
rook to the d file because of course
white will also develop his works on the
open d file uh we have h3 preparing to
kick away the knight with the g4 and
black of course prevents this with h5
but he doesn't just prevent g4 at some
point we are gonna develop the bishop to
e6 then knight to g5 could be somewhat
of an issue
attacking our bishop here if the knight
captures the bishop then we're gonna
have to mess up our pawn structure
capturing with the f-pawn by playing h5
we make room for a move like rook to h6
not at the moment at the moment the
bishop controls that but these guys know
what they're doing uh and the rook will
have very nice control of the e6 square
as well
bishop to f4 by nippo and now bishop to
e7 we have rook 8 to d1 of course
developing the rook to the only open
file on the board and bishop to e69 and
now as the bishop has been developed we
play knight to g5 hoping that black will
give up uh the one of the bishops but of
course that's not going to happen and
now as the knight blocked the bishop's
attack of the
h6 square we are welcome to play rook to
h6 you don't have to go bishop back to
c8 like nepal played when magnus played
knight to g5 because here the rook is
welcome
more than welcome on the h6 square so
this is what he plays we have rook f the
e1 now aligning the rook nicely with the
king on the e file and rook to d8
countering white's rook on the d-file we
have rook capture 78 king capture 78 and
now we have well before i tell you what
we have uh first we have to mention that
this position has been read before and
in two very very strong games uh one
where g4 was played sorry where g4 was
played uh there were okay maybe i'm
going to tell you this on the second
move uh there was a niche geary versus
rajab that ended in a draw where just
knight captures and e6 was played but
then again there's g4 which was played
in uh maxim bashar agra versus sergey
karjakin uh in this year's fide world
cup that also ended in the draw so i
think nepo is of course a very well
aware of this and he decided to improve
on that game and instead of going for
either of those two moves nepo played
knight seat e4 and it is now uh only as
uh off move 16 that we have a completely
new game so if you move it one move back
uh the move g4 that kayaking already
faced uh well while playing against mvl
uh is the engine's top recommendation
the move nipple plays knight seat to e4
is the engines well depending on what
engine you're using is the second or
third recommendation so uh trying to
take uh uh take him out of the well uh
position that he knows all too well
perhaps uh but who knows maybe these
guys have engines that are so strong
that maybe you know the one i'm using to
analyze
where it's a maybe second or third
suggestion maybe under super strong
powerful computers is maybe the first
thing the first continuation or maybe
even the 17th who knows uh what these
guys are using to you know get an edge
one over another either way knight cte
for a completely new game on the board
and now we have c5 always a useful move
when playing the berlin uh the king will
at some point maybe even be welcome on
the c6 square and you're gaining nice
control of some central squares you're
controlling d4 you're also controlling b
for if white gets an idea of maybe c3b
for a4 uh so uh always a useful move and
now what do you play here this is the
question uh you could try some exchanges
here like uh well you could open up an
attack towards the rook but that doesn't
really do anything if you play knight
captures on e6 we're just gonna play
rook captures on e6 we already said that
the rook on h6 will not be a liability
but you might try knight captures an f7
and open up an attack against the blue
black rook this way but still it's two
pieces for for the rogue bishop captures
bishop captures knight capture so we are
very happy with our bishop pair against
the white rook on e1 uh black is
definitely to be preferred here so the
move that nipple plays
is uh well just incredibly impressive he
plays knight to f6 and he asks sergey
what what do you play here because
there's so many things that you can play
here and obviously nipple came very very
well prepared so there are a couple of
things you could do obviously you could
capture the knight you could play g
captures an h6 you could ignore the
knight you could just move the rook as
you know some captures are happening
here so maybe your rook isn't all that
very well placed here on the h6 square
so we're going gonna discuss two of the
best replies uh for black and then we're
gonna show you what uh sergey played as
this is what this game is all about uh
featuring of course bobby fischer's move
if you do not know what i'm talking
about when i say bobby fischer's move
then you definitely have to check out
the bobby fischer saga that i made
already in its entirety it will be the
first link in the description below if
you have you know like a week maybe of
video watching available but okay here
uh some of the nicer ideas maybe are
just uh capturing an f7 so if this were
to happen not if someone for example
capturing on f6 g captures an f6 uh
white would play knight captures on e6
open up an attack against the rook f
captures an e6 will play bishop captures
an h6 knight captures and yes black does
have two pieces for a rook but he
captures an f6 with check sorry
attacking the bishop bishop captures and
now rook captures now the bishop cannot
move because the knight would fall so
knight the g8 the defending and now just
c3 not allowing bishop captures on b2
and you are very much uh okay here you
are uh up upon and also black's
pawn structure and on the queen side is
somewhat messed up so white would
definitely be okay here even though
you're fighting against a bishop and the
knight
so this is one thing that niepo is
proposing
uh sergey not really appreciating this
he tried something else so instead of g
captures an f6 uh you might also try a
move like uh bishop to c4 we're we're
really going after the bishop here so if
we just move the bishop it's a very very
complicated game because what is
happening here you can never capture
this knight but the white might try
something like b3 but then black would
very happily capture on f6 and now if e
captures an f6 attacking the bishop here
rook captures an f6 now we play b
captures in c4 and after i move like
king to d7 just getting our king into
the game black is perfectly fine here
nothing to worry about so the real idea
after bishop to c4 would be just moving
the knight saying that all right maybe
this is not such a great square for the
knight and then black might activate the
rook for example with rook to a6 and the
game continues with black not really
having anything to worry about but this
is all uh something that could have
happened but after knight to f6 uh
sergey played bobby fischer's move and
he played bishop captures on a2 which is
uh it seems like yeah of course it's a
free pawn has been hanging in there for
quite a while uh but uh uh niepo just
plays b3 and traps the bishop there so
now rook to a1 is coming at some point
and you're going to lose this bishop so
why did sergey play this well
there are a few reasons uh if you if you
go for the uh knight now which is
possible uh then the problem is knight
captures an f7 check is now available
and now after king 37 we're gonna
capture on h6 knight captures and now
again rook to a1 there's the problem of
the trap the bishop you're gonna have to
give it up for a pawn and the white is
now just up in exchange in uh well it
would be very very amazing if black was
able to to get a draw here so instead uh
cardiken tries um uh king to c8 and now
we have knight captures on f7 so
attacking the rook rook to g6 and not
knight to h8 again harassing this rook
asking what do you play here now if you
go back to h6 of course we're going to
very happily capture this rook with the
bishop so here rook captures on f6 was
played e captures on f6 and the bishop
capture so you're gonna lose the bishop
but uh at least you're not gonna be down
everything so bishop to e5 not allowing
in any tricks maybe g5 can come
at some point but it wouldn't really
matter because the bishop is controlling
the e5 square you can always play it and
defend your knight here so here bishop
to e5 right away we have bishop captures
rook captures and now knight to d4 going
after the c2 pawn uh but now rook
captures on c5 defending this pawn we
have b6 attacking durook rook to c4 and
now c5 so again getting a very nice pawn
chain here on the queen side defending
the knight but still
how is the bishop getting out well
rooked a4 attacking the bishop bishop to
b1 uh and now uh there's really no way
to further uh harass the bishop and now
c3 by nepo uh saying that okay if you
capture on b3 then you're gonna lose the
a7 pawn and then well my rook is super
active there's really not much for you
to uh look for in this position for
example g5 we're going to play knight to
f7 attack the pawn and if this then
captures captures and now it's uh three
pawns each but nipple would just be up
the exchange so he would very very much
win this position so after c3 we have
knight back to c6 by um and karjakin
defending that a7 pawn now comes knight
to f7 now we start bringing our knight
into the game bishop to c2 going after
this pawn but even rook to a3 a passive
square for the rook but uh it gets the
job done with a5 and now knight to d6
with check using this tempo to further
activate our knight king to c7 and now
knight to c4
so now the king is pretty much stuck
here regarding this b6 pawn if you play
b5 then you lose the a6 spawn uh so what
can you play we have knight to a7 going
after knight to b5 to attack the rook
and the c3 pawn and now knight to e3
attacking the bishop here this was the
plan all along we have to kick away the
bishop to be able to
move our pawns so bishop back to h7 all
the way there and now b4 you can't
capture with this pawn because the
knight hangs so first we have to play
knight to b5 attack the rook rook to a1
and now it doesn't really matter what
you play here with black if you play
knight captures on c3 uh then we play b
captures on c5 if you recapture then
we're gonna capture on a5 and even if
you don't we're still going to capture
here then this is going to be very weak
and
white kind of wants black kind of wants
his past pawn if he will have one to be
on the on the b file because the bishop
covers the b1 square so he doesn't want
to be left with a past a pawn if he is
to get some counter chances here so here
b5 could be played but then we're going
to play rook captures on a5 and then
after b4 rook to a7 check we're going to
go after this pawn uh for example king
to c6 now even knight to c4 the knight
can be placed on b2 to stop black's pass
pawn from advancing king captures on c5
knight b2 and now we're gonna just grab
all the stuff on the king side and the
knight here is uh stopping the b pawn
but only not only that preventing the
black king from reaching um
well anything important here uh to help
out with the advancement of the past b
pawn so after rook to a1 we don't have
knight captures and c3 uh sergey tries c
captures on b4 but just c captures on b
for a captures on b4 yes now black does
have a past b pawn uh that could be
promoted on b1 but now knight to d5
check this pawn will now fall king to d6
knight captures on b4 and he was in this
position on move 37 that sergey karjakin
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
it's uh equal pawns black's spawn
structure is messed up and nipple is up
the exchange uh between these two
gentlemen it would it would probably
even be considered an insult if if uh
karjakin were were to continue playing
this
uh so yeah a very nice victory for nepo
getting a win in the classical uh uh
time control which uh puts him to the to
the second place uh i don't have the
standings yet available for this video
but i will have them in the next one
because now all of the games have been
played uh but uh if you guys are
interested uh richard rapport is leading
the tournament followed by yanipong she
and only then magnus carlsen uh and
today we're gonna have round five which
will be the half mark of the tournament
and then we go into the second half
where we're going to have all the games
repeated only with colors reversed
uh so yeah that's the game great uh
great uh find by nepo finding a
classical game that uh karjakin played
this year uh and then improving on it
with such a brilliancy like knight to f6
it's just um you know and in in the
berlin defense you know everyone always
says nothing is ever happening in the
berlin
but that's the kind of guy that nepo is
he just finds stuff where there isn't
any stuff to be found
uh so yeah that's the game i really hope
you guys enjoyed it and that it at least
improved your sunday a little bit i
would like to thank john queenie matthew
coleman david chess tom derelo and the
beef aisle for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens uh in the chess world so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your sunday and also
bonus question if any of you are into
that what did you think of the new
matrix trailer see you soon guys